did you know that you're required to
know whether or not you have enough
runway for takeoffs and Landings in the
past you may have thought this was only
required for large airplanes because
they need a lot more Runway to make a
safe takeoff and Landing but I want to
show you something from the Federal
Aviation regulations in section 91-103
each pilot in command shall before
beginning a flight become familiar with
all available information concerning
that flight this information must
include Runway Links at airports of
intended use and the following takeoff
and Landing distance information for
civil aircraft for which an approved
airplane or rotorcraft flight manual
containing takeoff and Landing distance
data is required the takeoff and Landing
distance contain therein so according to
this you need to know the length of the
runways you're using and according to
this right here if there is a poh or
flight manual for the aircraft you have
to know how much runway you need for
takeoff and landing and if you have a
super old airplane that doesn't have a
poh or flight manual you may not have
performance tables but you still have to
have a reliable way to tell that you're
going to have enough runway in today's
video I'm going to explain performance
calculations in detail even if you're
familiar with takeoff and Landing
calculations you're going to want to
watch this video because we're going to
be talking about a lot more than
takeoffs and Landings because the
performance of your airplane can affect
a bunch of different aspects of flight
[Music]
okay so you want to be able to safely
control your airplane part of being able
to do that is to know its limitations or
capabilities unlike a car truck the
capabilities can change a lot when
you're flying an airplane for four main
reasons I'm going to discuss each one of
these in just a second but here's a
quick memory aid if you want to remember
all four of them remember the four h's
High hot heavy and humid okay so the
first thing that affects the performance
of our airplane is high altitude
specifically high pressure altitude
as I've explained in other lessons there
are a bunch of different kinds of
altitude on the average day or
technically what we call the standard
day the pressure at sea level is 29.92
inches of mercury then every thousand
feet of altitude that you climb the
pressure decreases one inch of mercury
now you and I both know that we almost
never have normal weather conditions
here on Earth so the pressure is almost
never exactly 29.92 inches when you get
the atis off the radio
so what we do is we spin a corrected
altimeter setting into the altimeter and
this gives us an accurate indicated
altitude when we're flying and this
allows us to fly safely over the top of
stuff and know that we're not going to
run into a tower or some other obstacle
but when it comes to Performance the
airplane doesn't care about that what it
cares about is how thin the air is or
how many air molecules you're flying
through and if we were to leave our
altimeter set at 29.92 inches this would
allow us to see exactly how much
pressure the outside air was putting on
the aircraft this is what we're calling
our pressure altitude it's a set
pressure and there's always a specific
altitude associated with a set pressure
because remember the pressure decreases
one inch of mercury every thousand feet
you climb before we continue I do want
to mention that if you're lucky enough
to fly on a day when the air pressure is
exactly 29.92 inches your pressure
altitude will be exactly the same as
your true altitude and your true
altitude is what they use to depict
obstacles mountains and basically all
the altitudes you see on a chart but the
indicated altitude that you see in your
airplane is actually going to be
slightly different than that even under
standard conditions and that's because
of instrument error I've discussed that
in much more detail in a few other
lessons so if you have questions be sure
to check those videos out
but with that in mind our airplane
doesn't care about true or indicated
altitude it cares about pressure
altitude because at high pressure
altitudes our airplane doesn't perform
as well and here's why as you may
remember from our lesson on weather and
the atmosphere the higher we go the less
air pressure there is so at high
pressure altitude there is less air
don't let this confuse you because it's
really not the best verbiage and it
confuses everyone at first high pressure
altitude means that we're higher up in
the atmosphere and there's less air
pressure up there but just remember
pressure altitude is the height we are
in feed above a specific air pressure of
29.92 inches this specific air pressure
is called the standard datum plane and
this is almost never the actual altitude
you're flying at so why does this low
pressure that we find at high pressure
altitudes hurt the performance of our
airplane while there's actually a few
reasons first in order to create power
your engine need fuel air and a spark or
heat
as we climb to higher pressure altitudes
there's less air up there to mix with
the fuel to create power
now we can lean out the fuel as we climb
higher which will give us a good fuel to
air ratio and this will give us the most
power possible but the more air we have
the more power we can produce that's why
some engines have turbochargers or
superchargers those devices actually
introduce more air into the engine but
the airplane you're flying probably
doesn't have either one of those but
it's something to think about because we
can produce more power at lower pressure
altitudes where there are more air
molecules
next our wings need air molecules
flowing over and under the wings to
create lift
higher pressure altitudes there are
fewer air molecules going over the wings
so your wings can't produce as much lift
because of this you're going to notice
that it's a lot harder to climb in areas
of high pressure altitude now it is true
that there is less drag on the airplane
so it is possible to travel faster
through the air around you as long as
your engine is able to produce enough
thrust to do that last but not least the
high pressure altitude affects our
propeller there's less air up at high
pressure altitudes for the propeller to
push the airplane forward I like to say
that the propeller can't get quite as
much bite on the air when the air is
thinner at these higher altitudes but no
matter what the case now you're starting
to see why the thinner air decreases our
performance now that you understand what
pressure altitude is now we need to know
how to calculate it because pressure
altitude is the starting point for all
our performance calculations
and there are actually four ways we can
calculate pressure altitude the first
and most accurate method is to use a
flight computer like this but I'm not
going to explain how to use one of these
in this video because there are so many
different types but these new digital
flight computers are a great way to make
these calculations you just have to Lug
one around everywhere you go the next
method is really easy but you have to be
in the airplane to use it all you have
to do is set 29.92 inches into the
colesman window on your altimeter and
whatever altitude you see in there is
your pressure altitude this might not be
super handy for pre-flight calculations
but you might find this useful at times
in the aircraft next is my favorite
method because you don't need any
special tools to use it all you have to
do is take the current altimeter setting
at your local field and subtract it from
the standard altimeter setting of 29.92
let's say the current altimeter setting
is 30.20 if we subtract that from 29.92
inches we get Negative point 2 8 . now
we simply multiply this times a thousand
because we lose an inch of mercury every
thousand feet
so that gives us negative 280 feet if
our field elevation was three thousand
feet MSL we'd subtract 280 from that to
get a pressure altitude of 2720 feet
what if our altimeter setting was 28.72
well in this case all we'd need to do is
subtract this from 29.92 just like we
did before but this time we get a
positive 1.2 so we'll multiply that
times 1000 to give us 1 200. so if our
field elevation was 3000 feet we just
add 1 200 to that so in this example our
pressure altitude is 4 200 feet one word
of caution if you use this method though
most instructors will agree that using
this method is plenty accurate for
almost all performance calculations but
technically this isn't the most accurate
method since pressure doesn't actually
drop exactly one inch of mercury every
thousand feet as you can see from this
chart it's not quite an inch every
thousand feet and by looking at this you
can also see that higher air pressure
like this decreases our pressure
altitude and lower air pressure like you
see up here increases our pressure
altitude now you're starting to see why
people get confused pressure altitude
isn't the best name but that's what we
call it and speaking of that this chart
is another way to find your pressure
altitude this is what we call a pressure
altitude conversion chart this is one of
the easiest ways to calculate pressure
altitude and on the written test this
method is what you need to use because
this is going to give you the best
answer for the test questions sometimes
you'll find this chart in the
performance section of newer pohs2 so
you might like this method if you keep
this chart in a handy spot for future
reference let's say the field elevation
is a thousand feet MSL and the altimeter
setting is 30.80
all we need to do to use this chart is
to look over here at the altimeter
setting on the side and look at the
number next to it in this example our
altitude is negative 803 feet so all we
have to do is subtract 803 from our
field elevation of a thousand feet so
our pressure altitude in this example is
197 feet okay so now that we know how to
do that we need to take a look at one of
the other four h's that decrease the
performance of our airplane hot now I
know you're thinking I'm referring to my
great looks but I'm actually referring
to hot outside air temperature and the
reason that hot outside air temperature
affects the performance of our airplane
is because when the air temperature is
hotter the air molecules actually spread
apart when the air molecule spread apart
the air gets less dense or thinner and
that literally means that there's less
air for the engine to take in and less
air for our wings to create lift and
less air for our propeller to create
thrust it's literally the same reason
why our performance is bad at high
pressure altitude basically the air is
thinner
and because that temperature can affect
our performance just like pressure
altitude we want to take that into
account when we calculate performance
to do that we start with our pressure
altitude pressure altitude is always
going to be the starting point for all
our performance calculations
then if the temperature is standard
which is 15 degrees Celsius you're
typically going to get the best
performance out of your airplane but if
it's hotter than that your pressure
altitude may stay the same but your
airplane thinks it's at a higher
altitude because there's less air
pressure
and while your actual altitude may not
have changed your airplane's performance
is going to get worse because it's at a
higher density altitude density altitude
is the altitude your airplane thinks
it's at your airplane only cares about
the air pressure around it if the air
pressure is lower than the standard
pressure your pressure altitude is going
to be higher because there's less air
pressure up there and if the temperature
is hotter than standard temperature your
density altitude is going to be higher
because there's also less air pressure
because those air molecules spreading
apart from the heat but how do we
calculate density altitude well we start
with a pressure altitude pressure
altitude is always the starting point
for all our performance calculations
just keep in mind when the temperature
is standard which is 15 degrees Celsius
density altitude and pressure altitude
are exactly the same which means that if
temperature is standard and the air
pressure is standard or 29.92 inches
density altitude and true altitude are
the same as well and by the way
sometimes you'll see this weird acronym
Isa on some of your charts that just
stands for international standard
atmosphere basically all this is is a
fancy way of saying 15 degrees Celsius
or a pressure setting of 29.92
I don't know why they do this but it's
something to watch out for
now there is one other thing that
affects density altitude and that's
humidity humidity also pushes those air
molecules farther apart which also
decreases the performance of our engine
wings and propeller just like the hotter
air temperatures now humidity is one of
those four things that we talk about
that affects the performance of our
airplanes but we don't typically
calculate that because the calculations
start to get way too complicated and it
doesn't affect performance quite as much
as the other three factors but it's
definitely something you want to
consider when you're thinking about
performance okay so now we know that if
our outside air temperature increases
above 15 degrees Celsius our density
altitude also increases with that
temperature increase and we can
calculate how much it increases a few
different ways the first method is with
the flight computer like this this is a
super quick and easy way to get your
density altitude start with your
pressure altitude in this window right
here let's say our pressure altitude is
3000 feet let's find 3 on this inner
ring right here then we'll find the
current outside air temperature on this
outer ring here let's say it's 25
degrees Celsius and rotate that over to
3000 feet then we can read our density
altitude Above This arrow in this window
here it looks like our density altitude
is 5000 feet
as you can see the outside air
temperature can have a huge impact on
how high the airplane thinks it is
that's why it's so important to know how
to do this
the next method is to use a chart like
this this is pretty simple as well and
this is really the method you need to
use on the written exam because this is
going to get you the closest to the test
answer that the FAA is looking for
start with your temperature down here at
the bottom once again let's say our
temperature is 25 degrees Celsius
then move up until we hit a pressure
altitude of 3000 feet
then we just move straight over from
there to get a density altitude of about
4 500 feet as you can see that's about a
500 foot difference from our flight
computer that's not going to make a huge
difference when it comes to calculating
performance but it could be the
difference in a right and wrong answer
on the written test though
okay so now that you know all that let's
briefly talk about the last of the four
h's High hot heavy and humid heavyweight
is the only thing we haven't talked
about now this one's kind of common
sense because if your airplane weighs
more it's going to be harder to get the
airplane off the ground on a takeoff and
it's going to be harder to stop the
airplane when you're heavy on a landing
if you weigh more your wings have to
create more lift in order to offset that
heavy weight
and the propeller has to create more
thrust to pull the weight forward like I
said all this is common sense so I'm not
going to really explain it anymore today
but you'll see in a minute how big of a
difference the weight of your airplane
makes for takeoff and Landing distances
alright before we move on let's take a
quick look at the relationship between
all these things so I know for sure you
have a good understanding of all this
when you go to make your calculations
when we're talking about performance we
need to start with the field elevation
this is going to be shown in true
altitude or we could also start with a
cruise altitude if we wanted and this
would be an indicated altitude from
these we can convert to pressure
altitude by accounting for non-standard
air pressure like we talked about
earlier because remember pressure isn't
always exactly 29.92 inches at sea level
every day but the pressure altitude is
our distance above 29.92 inches not
necessarily the pressure that day from
there we can get our density altitude by
accounting for non-standard temperature
if the temperature is exactly 15 degrees
pressure altitude and density altitude
are the same if the temperature is below
15 the density altitude will be below
the pressure altitude and if it's above
15 degrees then the density altitude
will be higher than the PA and now that
you know that and how the four h's
affect performance let's start making
some actual calculations so you know
with absolute certainty that you're
going to be safe when you go fly the
first calculations you need to know how
to make are takeoff calculations do I
have enough Runway to make the take off
or am I going to go off the end of the
runway before I get airborne
to figure that out we need to look at
the Pilot's operating handbook or poh
for our airplane
in newer pohs the performance section
will be in section 5. so if you have a
paperback version of your poh I would
really recommend tabbing that section
out
now in the poh you're typically going to
find tables like this to calculate
performance but for the written test
they're going to give you this evil
looking spaghetti chart right here
I'm sorry if you need to change out your
underwear after seeing this thing but I
promise you that it's not nearly as bad
as it looks it's actually really simple
and what they're going to do is they're
going to give you the current weather
situation and they're going to ask you
how much runway you need to take off in
these conditions
all right so let's start with our
temperature let's say that once again
it's 25 degrees Celsius outside and our
pressure altitude is 3000 feet
start down here at the bottom and move
straight up until we hit a pressure
altitude of 3000 feet notice there isn't
a 3000 foot mark on this chart we kind
of have to estimate where that is these
lines indicating pressure altitude
aren't perfectly straight we kind of
have to imagine where another curved
line would be
in this case the curved line would be
halfway between the 2000 foot and the
four thousand foot Mark so this is where
we'll stop our line going up then we'll
move straight over from there until we
hit one of these reference lines
now this time we got really lucky
because we hit our reference line right
on one of these black guidelines
this makes things really easy when this
happens all we need to do is follow this
guideline until the guideline hits our
weight
in this example our weight is 2 500
pounds so we'll stop it right here but
if your previous line hit a spot
somewhere between these guidelines you
just kind of have to estimate where that
should be by staying the same distance
between two guidelines above and below
your current numbers then once you hit
your weight you'd move straight over
from there until you hit the next
reference line
okay so I'll move straight over from
here and this time I'm hitting my
reference line just barely under one of
these guidelines but wait a second we've
got two sets of guidelines here I've got
these hash guidelines and these solid
guidelines don't worry just look at the
labels the hatch lines are for a
tailwind and the solid lines are for a
headwind let's take a quick peek at the
end of the chart notice that anytime we
move up the chart our takeoff distance
increases and anytime we move down the
chart our takeoff distance decreases so
as you can see if we have a headwind we
don't need quite as much runway on a
takeoff and now you can also see how
much our weight affects our takeoff
distance
and you can see that the temperature and
pressure altitude have a tremendous
effect on it as well
but anyway let's get back to this chart
let's say we have a headwind of 10 knots
this time so we'll stay just below this
guideline until we hit a headwind of 10
knots
then we'll move straight over to the
next reference line
okay now we've got a decision to make is
there an obstacle at the end of the
runway that we need to clear
it's not uncommon for there to be a tree
or something at the end of the runway at
some airports and we obviously don't
want to hit that thing if you do I don't
want to be your instructor
but anyway what this chart does is it
artificially lengthens the amount of
Runway that we need so we're Airborne
before we get to the tree so we'll be
well above the tree by the time we get
there now we'll discuss this more when
we talk about short field takeoffs but
it's super important that we climb out
of VX once we're Airborne if we're going
to do this
this takeoff distance is calculated
based on the assumption that you're
going to be climbing out at VX and if
you're climbing out at VY instead you
may not have artificially shortened your
Runway enough to clear the obstacle
anyway if you don't have an obstacle all
you need to do is move straight across
this chart to the end it looks like in
this example we need 760 feet of Runway
but if I had a 30 foot obstacle to clear
then I want to stay about the same
distance in between these two guidelines
and move up the chart until I hit my 30
feet then move straight across from
there to see that I need 1 150 feet of
Runway
now on the written test this is what you
want to do but if you need to do this in
real life for an obstacle I highly
recommend just moving all the way up the
chart until you hit the 50-foot obstacle
Mark and if you do that you can see that
you need closer to 1 300 feet of Runway
now this is a good time to talk about
this because the book answer that you're
going to be calculating on the written
exam is not always the best answer when
you start making these calculations for
flight take a look at this note in the
chart supplement for the airport over at
Calico Rock they tell us that the
threshold Crossing height or TCH is 29
feet for some trees at the end of the
runway let's call it 30 feet to be safe
the big question is when was that tree
measured and did they even measure or is
that just a big fat guess also these
distance calculations you see in the poh
were numbers that the manufacturer came
up with when the aircraft was brand new
if you're flying a 50 year old airplane
like I regularly do it's a good idea to
give yourself a safety buffer because
the old girl probably doesn't fly quite
like she used to
another thing you need to consider is
your abilities as a pilot when the
manufacturer came up with these numbers
they used a test pilot who probably had
thousands of hours worth of experience
and they probably had an unlimited
number of attempts to get the best
possible performance out of the airplane
so unless you're Chuck Yeager Jr you may
consider adding a little bit of a safety
buffer for this as well now that I've
shown you how to calculate takeoff
distance with this stupid spaghetti
chart for the written exam let's take a
look at how to make these calculations
from an actual Poh you're more likely to
use a takeoff table like this when
you're making real calculations so want
to spend a few minutes talking about
that now
okay before we start doing anything it's
really important that you're flying the
airplane according to these conditions
mentioned at the top of the chart
otherwise the takeoff information this
thing's giving us is not going to be
accurate for example if you want to get
accurate numbers it's really important
that we're at or below this takeoff
weight of 2 200 pounds if we're above
this weight we need to make sure that we
find the appropriate chart for that
weight or lower the takeoff weight
somehow now notice that this thing says
that we're going to need to take off
with 10 degrees of flaps and we need to
start with full power prior to break
release
now you might not know what the
significance of this is yet unless
you're farther along in your training
but these conditions let us know that we
need to use short filled takeoff
procedures if we want the runway length
to be accurate if you do a normal
takeoff you'll need more Runway than
this chart tells you but we don't know
exactly how much that's one thing I
really don't like about this Cessna 172
Sierra Poh if the Federal Aviation
regulations require you to know the
takeoff distance every time you go fly
they should really include a normal
takeoff distance chart in here as well
my personal recommendation is to double
the takeoff distance from this chart if
you're going to use normal takeoff
procedures just to be safe and if you're
below those numbers I would use short
field takeoff procedures on your take
off then you'll know for sure the exact
amount of Runway you need anyway this is
something to watch out for because this
takeoff table in the poh from my Cessna
172 Hotel shows the flaps up for takeoff
and it doesn't specify that you have to
use short filled takeoff procedures but
if you're ever close on your numbers I
would highly recommend that you err on
the side of caution and use short fill
takeoff procedures they aren't that
difficult to do
anyway let's go back to our Cessna 172
Sierra takeoff chart and let's say we're
going to use short field takeoff
procedures okay the temperature today is
20 degrees Celsius and our pressure
altitude is 3 000 feet
now we can see here that our ground roll
is 925 feet but our total takeoff
distance to clear a 50-foot obstacle is
1570 feet pretty simple but let's take a
quick look at these notes down here at
the bottom to make sure there's
something we're not forgetting
okay so if we're taking off from a field
with an elevation of over 3000 feet we
need to make sure that we lean the
mixture out properly remember if we
don't do that we're not going to get the
best power out of our engine because the
air is thinner at higher altitudes and
we want to get the most power out of our
engine even though we're not going to
get a hundred percent power at this
altitude
all right next this note says we can
decrease our takeoff Distance by 10 for
every nine knots of headwind
let's say we have a headwind of nine
knots usually I'll just select not to do
this to give myself a little bit of a
safety buffer but if we're in a pinch we
could multiply 0.1 times our ground rule
of 925 feet to see that a nine knot
headwind would allow us to take off 92.5
feet sooner then we have this note right
here that basically says that we need
more Runway if we're taking off on dry
grass this is because grass creates a
ton of drag now this doesn't really
apply in our case but it's something to
keep in mind
okay okay I got a little lucky this time
my temperature and pressure altitude was
perfect for this chart and more than
likely this is never going to happen
let's say the outside air temperature is
25 degrees and our pressure altitude is
3500 now what well we can do one of two
things sometimes when I'm in a pinch
I'll round up to the next higher
temperature and the next higher pressure
altitude to give me a worst case
scenario takeoff distance
in this situation I have a ground rule
of a thousand and ninety feet and I
would need 1 855 feet in order to clear
a 50-foot obstacle this is ultra
conservative and this is totally legal
but if you need something a little more
precise because you're really close on
your numbers you can interpolate between
these two sections there are a couple
ways you can do this but I'll show you
the easiest way to do it let's say this
time we want to know our takeoff ground
rule we're really not concerned about an
obstacle this time so let's take our
takeoff distance from our best case
scenario first that would be this 20
degree line because 20 is the next
column below 25 degrees then we'll find
3 000 foot line because 3 000 feet
pressure altitude is the next row
underneath the pressure altitude of
3500.
okay so this line gives us a ground rule
of 925 feet now let's find the worst
case scenario
the next temperature column above 25
degrees is 30 and the pressure altitude
above 3500 is 4000. so let's move down
these to see that in a worst case
scenario we need to take off ground roll
of 1090 feet of Runway
now because 25 is exactly halfway
between 20 and 30 and 3500 is exactly
halfway between three thousand and four
thousand if we average out our two
takeoff distances we can get a pretty
accurate ground rule to do that all we
have to do is add 925 and 1090 for a
total of 2015. then divide that by two
to get a ground rule of a thousand and
seven point five feet now once again
this is only accurate if the numbers
fall perfectly between these two numbers
on the chart
if they're a little to one side or
another you could use this interpolation
formula if you want but as you can see
that is entirely too much work
if you are more than halfway between
these numbers I would just recommend
using the higher of these two charts and
going with those numbers but remember
these numbers were made by a test pilot
so it's not going to hurt to have a
safety buffer and just use those higher
numbers now there are apps that will
interpolate for you very quickly and
accurately and you can use one of those
if you want for pre-flight calculations
but that's not really going to help you
on the written test and once again I'd
just rather round up to the nearest
Chart to be safe interpolating these
numbers literally only gave us 82.5
additional feed and personally that's
way too close for comfort for me okay
now let's take a look at the Landing
charts so you know for a fact you're
going to have enough Runway when we come
in for a landing typically you'll find
that most airplanes need less Runway to
land than they do for a takeoff but you
still need to know how to find these
numbers
good grief another stupid spaghetti
chart yeah sorry the FAA wants to know
for sure that you're going to know how
to use one of these but don't worry I
won't spend too much time explaining
this one because it works just like the
takeoff chart notice just like the
takeoff chart there's some conditions we
need to meet if we want the numbers on
the chart to be accurate with the
numbers we actually need for one they're
assuming that you're going to be
carrying some power down final and
they're also assuming that you're going
to have all your flaps down now if
you're a regular viewer of this channel
you probably remember a video I made a
few months ago talking about this in
excruciating detail if you haven't
watched that yet you're going to love
that video I highly recommend it anyway
if you land with flaps up you're
completely invalidating your Landing
data and the runway length you calculate
at the end here is not going to be
correct that's why it's so important
that we follow these conditions very
carefully on these charts especially
when we know that Landing distance is a
factor and notice there are a few other
conditions we need to meet as well if we
want our calculations to be accurate
including landing at the appropriate
indicated air speed if you're that guy
who's constantly fast when you're
crossing the threshold that Landing
distance you see here at the end will be
wrong okay so let's say our outside air
temperature today is 5 degrees Celsius
and our PA is 2000 feet let's move up
from 5 degrees until we hit our 2000
foot guideline then we'll move over
until we hit our next reference line
and our way today is 2 400 pounds so
let's stay in between these two
guidelines at roughly the same interval
and continue down until we hit two
thousand four hundred pounds
once we're there let's move straight
over to the next reference line now as
you know we should not normally be
landing with the Tailwind but let's say
we are this time so you can see how much
it affects our Landing distance
let's say we're Landing with a 10 knot
Tailwind so we'll move up the chart here
until we hit our 10 knot line then move
straight over from here to the next
reference line now check out how much
this Landing distance a 10 knot Tailwind
adds in this example
500 feet yeah that's insane isn't it
I've actually made a lot of Tailwind
Landings and if you ever make one you'll
notice a tremendous difference in the
distance that the airplane floats before
you touch down and your ground speed is
also way faster because you're traveling
over the ground 10 knots faster and this
makes it harder to get the airplane
stopped okay so now you can see that we
have an obstacle section on this chart
as well because obstacles can affect our
Landing distance as well if we're not
Landing over an obstacle we just move
straight across the chart like we did in
the takeoff chart and it looks like we
need 1 470 feet of ground roll and
notice how they use the term ground roll
instead of the term Landing distance and
that's a very important thing to keep in
mind ground rule means the distance
after you touch down all the way until
your stopping point it does not include
the runway length you cover during the
round out and flare this is why I like
to use the threshold as my AimPoint when
I'm landing on a short Runway instead of
the captain's bars unless I have a crazy
Tailwind or I make a big mistake I know
for a fact I'm going to land between two
and 300 feet beyond that point so for my
personal calculations I'll typically add
300 feet to my ground rule required to
account for that and to give me a total
Landing distance
if you're new you might like to add 500
feet or more to be safe and account for
this however they're most likely not
going to want you to do this on the
written test they're only going to want
you to find your ground rule or the
landing distance over an obstacle and
that raises a good point what if we're
Landing over an obstacle well typically
this increases your Landing distance
because you have to plan on shifting
your aim Point further down the runway
to miss the obstacle there are ways to
keep from doing this like a forward slip
but I would never recommend that you
disregard that additional Landing
distance just because you know a trick
for getting down to the runway sooner so
let's see how much runway I would need
if there's a 50-foot obstacle at the
approach end of a Runway
let's see I'd say that's exactly 2 200
feet
yes I know it seems long but remember we
have a 10 knot Tailwind if we land the
other direction that would turn that 10
knot Tailwind into a 10 knot headwind
and you can see that this alone would
reduce our Landing Distance by almost a
thousand feet
now you're starting to see why we like
to land into the wind now on the written
exam they may also ask you questions
with a landing distance table like this
and once again this type of chart is
much more common in small airplanes than
a spaghetti chart and this one is so
similar to the table from the Cessna 172
Sierra poh that I'm just going to use
this one from the poh so you don't get
used to seeing all those pretty colors
I'd hate for you to expect everything in
flying to be color coded for you and if
you didn't notice that this chart was
color coded you may want to get your
color vision checked because a
colorblindness diagnosis can really come
out of the blue
anyway just like our takeoff distance
table we have conditions that we need to
meet in order to know for sure that
these numbers are accurate as you can
see here we need to have 30 degrees of
Flaps in we need to have the power at
idle on touchdown and we need to use
maximum braking also this data is for a
paved level dry Runway and this chart is
for zero wind
as you can see in the notes Here If we
have a headwind we can decrease our
Landing Distance by 10 percent for every
nine knots of headwind and check this
out every two knots of Tailwind adds 10
percent that's insane that's why it's
super important to land into the wind if
your Runway required is close to the
runway distance you have available
in addition to all that at 50 feet we
need to be at 61 knots now this raises a
good point that we don't talk about too
often first if we're faster than 61
knots at 50 feet our Landing distance is
going to be longer than what we see here
but what about once we're below 50 feet
this chart actually assumes that you
will slow below your landing speed as
you cross the threshold now I want to be
careful about how I say this because
some dingleberry is going to take this
the wrong way install their plane right
before they make the runway but when you
start the round out your air speed
should start to gradually decrease all
the way until you touch down if you're
struggling with floating Landings it's a
good chance that this is your problem
you're waiting too long to start slowing
down and last but not least if we want
to make sure these numbers are accurate
we need to make sure that we're using
the short filled Landing procedures
appropriately okay let's go ahead and
calculate our Landing distance let's say
we weigh 2 550 pounds this time our
outside air temperature is 14 degrees
Celsius and our pressure altitude is 4
300 feet okay well 15 degrees is the
exact middle of 10 and 20 degrees and 14
degrees is slightly below that and 4 500
is the exact middle of four thousand and
five thousand feet so if we interpolate
between these two charts using the
average method our runway length won't
be perfect but we know for a fact that
the length that this gives us will be
slightly high and that's conservative so
let's go ahead and do that okay so 10
degrees and four thousand feet gives us
a ground roll of 655 feet and a landing
distance over a 50-foot Obstacle of 1460
feet
20 degrees and 5000 feet gives us a 705
foot ground rule and a 1 535 foot
Landing distance over an obstacle let's
say we're Landing over an obstacle today
so let's add 1460 and 1535 for a total
of 2995 then divide that by two to see
that we need one thousand four hundred
ninety seven point five feet of Runway
now remember this number isn't perfect
because technically this isn't right in
the middle of these two charts but our
numbers are legal and conservative
because with our conditions we actually
need a little less Runway than what we
see here
with that in mind if my temperature was
16 degrees and my pressure altitude was
4 600 I would use this ground roll of
705 feet and the obstacle Landing
distance of 1 535 feet and I wouldn't
even consider landing on anything
shorter than that the only exception to
that would be if we had a headwind of
nine knots or more then we could shorten
it the same way we did the takeoff
distance now check this out this note
says that we should increase our ground
roll distance if we're landing on a dry
grass Runway and believe me the word dry
here is super important I about how to
clean my pants out one time because I
landed on a short grass Runway that was
covered in Dew it's probably more like
50 or 60 percent on a wet grass Runway I
wish they throw that information in
these pohs that would be really nice to
know anyway so if we take our ground
rule of 705 feet and we multiply that
times 0.45 that grass increases our
Landing distance another
317.25 feet
and this gives us a total Landing
distance of
1022.25 feet
now I know this seems kind of weird
because grass adds drag on a landing but
the reason why grass Landings add so
much distance is because most Pilots
tend to add a little power right before
touchdown and we also try to avoid
breaks as much as possible to keep our
nose wheel from digging into the dirt
okay let's talk about a few more things
that you need to know when it comes to
Performance first let's spend a few
minutes talking about crosswind charts
now in some aircraft pohs you'll find
that the airplane may be limited on how
strong of a crosswind you can take off
or land in but in a lot of airplane pohs
you'll find something like this that was
obviously written by a lawyer in this
poh it says the maximum allowable
crosswind velocity is dependent on the
pilot capability as well as airplane
limitations operation and direct
Crosswinds of 15 knots has been
demonstrated basically they're saying
that if you land with a crosswind
component more than 15 knots you're a
test pilot at that point now it doesn't
say you can't but I would highly
recommend against it until you get a lot
more skill under your belt and you
become extremely familiar with that
aircraft so for the time being let's say
that we can't land with a crosswind
component of more than 15 knots in this
airplane but how do we know if we have a
15 knot crosswind component the wind is
almost never going to be a straight 90
degree crosswind and that means that we
have to make some calculations and if we
have a quartering headwind we might also
need to know how strong our headwind
component is because remember if it's
nine knots or more on this airplane that
will actually shorten our takeoff and
Landing distance and we might want to
know that
okay so let's say we're landing on
Runway three six and we have winds from
three two zero at 30 knots
are we going to exceed our crosswind
component limit of 15 knots when you go
to take your written exam you're going
to need to use this chart right here but
in a minute I'll show you a simple way
that you can figure this out in your
head without digging out this stupid
little chart so you can focus on flying
the airplane and not fumbling for this
chart when you need to focus on Landing
okay anyway the first thing we need to
do is find the difference between the
wind direction and the runway heading to
do that I'll just subtract 3 2 0 from
our Runway heading a 360 for Runway
three six so it looks like we have a
wind angle of 40 degrees okay now all we
have to do is find 40 degrees out here
and move in until we hit our wind speed
of 30 knots okay now we can read our
headwind component over here and if you
look closely at this chart you can tell
that our headwind component is almost
exactly 23 knots maybe a tiny bit over
that and if we wanted we could actually
use this headwind component to reduce
our takeoff in landing distances like I
mentioned a second ago and if you
remember our chart said we could reduce
our distances by 10 percent for every
nine knots of headwind so we could
actually reduce our Runway distance
required by 20 percent if we wanted
anyway now we can move straight down the
chart to see our crosswind component
looks like our crosswind component is
just over 19 knots which is beyond our
15 knot limit
so we really need to find another Runway
but as you can see this chart is super
easy to use okay before we move on I
want to show you another way you could
get access on the written test because I
don't want the FAA getting the best of
you what is the maximum wind velocity
for your aircraft if the winds are at a
50 degree angle Off The Runway and your
airplane's crosswind limit is 20 knots
don't let this confuse you all you have
to do is run the chart backwards we know
that 20 knots is our crosswind limit so
let's move up from 20 knots on the
crosswind component axis and move up
until we hit our 50 degree line from
here we kind of have to imagine where
our wind velocity circle is I would say
it's about 26 knots so if our wind
velocity is 26 knots or more and our win
really is 50 degrees or more Off The
Runway heading we need to find another
Runway okay now I'm going to show you a
method that's actually useful in the
airplane it's called The Clock method
and this is going to keep you from
digging out this stupid little chart
when you really need to focus on flying
the airplane unlike my students looking
outside and not at these tiny little
crosswind charts when they're trying to
land the plane to use this method
imagine an old-fashioned analog clock
now let's let every hour on the clock
represent 5 degrees of wind angle from
the runway
at the three o'clock position which is
15 degrees Off The Runway we'll take a
quarter of the wind velocity at six
o'clock or 30 degrees Off The Runway
we'll take half of the wind velocity at
nine o'clock or 45 degrees Off The
Runway we'll take three quarters of the
wind velocity and at 12 o'clock or 60
degrees we'll take all of it and
obviously if the winds are straight down
the pipe we won't have a crosswind
component all right now that you know
all that let's try it out let's say
we're landing on Runway one five and the
Windsor 135 at 15 knots first we'll find
our wind angle by subtracting 135
degrees from 150. that gives us a wind
angle of 15 degrees okay so 15 degrees
is at our 3 o'clock position and we said
that we're taking a quarter of the wind
velocity there so our crosswind
component is exactly 3.75 knots not too
bad that's barely even across wind let's
do another one but this time let's say
they give us this picture here and tell
us the winds are zero four five at 28
knots which Runway should we use are we
going to be able to land the plane here
if our airplane's Max crosswind
component is 20 knots
pause the video if you think you can
solve this one on your own and I'll show
you my calculations once you're done
okay how many people did I get with this
one Runway two two and Runway zero four
are closed so the only runways available
are Runway three six and one eight but
just for fun we'll take a look at the
crosswind on both of them okay so Runway
1A and two two are definitely out of the
picture because we have a Tailwind on
those runways but if we subtract 40 for
Runway 4 from the wind direction of zero
four five you can see that our wind
angle is 5 degrees then for Runway three
six that one's easy because 45 degrees
is 45 degrees off from that one okay
let's start with the clock method then
we'll compare the results with the
crosswind component chart let's see
Runway zero four is five degrees off and
the wind speed is 28 knots five degrees
is closest to the 12 o'clock position
and if the winds are straight down the
pipe we don't have a crosswind component
so let's call our crosswind zero knots
now let's use the chart and see what the
difference is let's find five degrees on
the chart and move down until we hit a
wind speed of 28 knots then we'll move
down the chart from there until we hit
our crosswind component scale looks like
our crosswind is exactly two knots I'd
say the clock method is close enough in
this case wouldn't you okay so now let's
try Runway three six okay so our angle
off is 45 degrees and that's at the nine
o'clock position so let's take three
quarters of the wind speed to get our
crosswind component three quarters of 28
is exactly 21. so according to the clock
method our crosswind component is 21
knots and this is just over a 20 knot
crosswind limit let's try the chart just
to be sure I'll start here on the 45
degree line and move down until we hit
28 knots
then move straight down from there I'm
getting somewhere between 20 and 21 not
crosswind component so in reality since
Runway 4 is closed we should be finding
another airport to land at this is why
you need to learn how to divert to
another Airfield and I hope to discuss
this in a future video but once again if
this 20 knot limit is a maximum
demonstrated limit and not a do not
exceed number and you've been flying for
a while and you're comfortable giving it
a shot you can always give it a try and
worst case you can always go around if
you need to okay so let's talk about
something else that affects the
performance of our aircraft for a minute
drag now I briefly discussed this in
some of my earlier aerodynamic videos
but it's really important to bring this
up when you're talking about performance
as you may remember our airplane needs
to create lift in order to fly and the
way it does that is by getting air to
flow over and under the wings now if
there isn't a lot of air flowing over
the wings because the airplane is moving
too slowly the wings need to be at a
higher angle of attack in order to
maintain level fly and an even higher
angle of attack in order to climb well
what does that mean it means that we're
also producing more drag at slow air
speeds because we're at higher angles of
attack and you'll notice that when
you're flying faster the nose of the
airplane will be lower when you're
trying to maintain altitude and even
while you're climbing in fact in some
airplanes when you're flying at high air
speeds your nose will actually be below
the Horizon just to maintain level fly
this drag that is a result of the lift
that our airplane is producing is called
induced drag we are inducing the drag as
a byproduct of the lift that we're
creating and as you can see from this
chart our induced drag decreases as we
speed up but what happens when you stick
your hand out of the window of a car the
faster you're going the more the wind
rips your hand back and that's why all
the little parts and pieces on the
airplane get caught in this wind flow
and try holding the airplane back just
like your hand this is what we call
parasite drag
and as we fly faster parasite drag
increases and if we were to average out
the parasite and induced drag what we
would get is this curved line right here
and as you can see we have this magical
little zone right here where we have the
least amount of drag on our airplane we
call this little spot LD Max or lift
over drag to the max because this is
giving us the best ratio of lift to drag
for the air speed you're flying okay so
who cares well oddly enough a lot of air
speeds on your airplane are directly
related to this air speed at which LD
Max occurs if you want to get the best
fuel efficiency or best range on your
airplane typically it's right in this
area where you have the least amount of
drag
if you're making an emergency descent
Your Best Glide is going to be right
around this spot where there's the least
amount of drag on your airplane what
about when we're climbing out on a
takeoff
while VY is going to be super close to
this LD Max Speed because we want the
least amount of drag on our airplane and
this AirSpeed is going to allow us to
climb up to a certain altitude as
quickly as possible
but if I wasn't concerned about the time
it took me to get up to altitude and I
wanted my wings to create a little more
lift I could increase my angle of attack
a little more and climb out at a steeper
angle yes I've increased the drag on my
airplane but I've also increased the
lift my airplane is producing and that's
a good thing that's actually what I want
if I'm trying to clear an obstacle at
the end of the runway and that's what
we're trying to accomplish when we climb
out at VX instead of Vy we're basically
sacrificing a little bit of speed by
inducing more drag and trading it for
more lift
in addition to all that when you're
below this LD Max number the way you
control the airplane will be a little
bit different as well
when we're below LD Max typically the
most effective way to speed up is to
reduce our angle of attack by pitching
down and power doesn't really speed us
up like it should because we have so
much drag on the airplane and we need to
get the airplane closer to LD Max where
there's less drag we're essentially
trading drag for AirSpeed that's why
during slow flight we use pitch to
control our air speed and power to
control our altitude with that in mind
let's take a quick look at a couple more
charts that you should be familiar with
now we know that if we climb out of Vy
we'll be able to climb out at the best
rate but how fast is that well we can
figure that out with a rate of climb
chart like this if the pressure altitude
is 4 000 feet and our temperature is 20
degrees and we're climbing out at v y we
can expect 555 feet per minute and this
is handy because you can use this
information to figure out how long it's
going to take you to get to your cruise
altitude if I was climbing from four
thousand to six thousand feet that's two
thousand feet of climb distance so I
could just divide that by 555 feet per
minute to see that it's going to take me
3.6 minutes to get up there that's about
3 minutes and 36 seconds okay here's a
couple other charts that I've explained
in detail on my cross-country navigation
videos as you can see these also take
the airplane's weight the pressure
altitude and the outside air temperature
into account to give you accurate
performance numbers so you can calculate
your time Fuel and distance because
these are things you're going to want to
know when you start flying cross country
now I know there's a lot of information
in today's episode but if you can
remember anything from today's video
remember the four h's High hot heavy and
humid if I'm operating at a high
pressure altitude if it's hot outside if
it's humid outside or if my airplane is
super heavy I'm not going to get the
performance I'm used to
if I don't have enough runway in front
of me my best option is probably to wait
for the temperature to cool down
leaving gear or passengers behind is an
option as well if you want to reduce
your weight especially if it's someone
you don't like but that might not be a
realistic option in some cases
especially if it's your mother-in-law
now as we discussed a headwind can be a
tremendous help as well but as you know
the wind is susceptible to change so I
would just be careful using it to help
your numbers but I would always count on
it if it looks like it's going to hurt
your numbers I hope you enjoyed today's
video and I hope you learned something
in my next video I'm going to start
digging into the regulations you need to
know as a Private Pilot you're not going
to want to miss that video because you
need to know the information and I
promise I'll make it fun and when I'm
finished with that video I'll throw it
right here or if you want to take a
break from studying a bit and you want
to enjoy some flying try this video
enjoy the flight sit
you're not gonna believe this I just
bought a free pilot training I'm going
to keep on watching